[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de 7,8 échos le magazine consacré
à l'actualité économique de notre
territoire sans plus tarder voici le
sommaire de prêts d'honneur de 5000 à
75000 euros à taux zéro et sans garantie
c'est ce que propose 50 en yvelines avec
les prés initiative
focus sur deux entreprises saint
quentinois jpm pliage et aksoy qui ont
pu en bénéficier
jean-luc méro directeur entreprises
animations économie qui emploie 50 en
yvelines sera également en plateau
retour sur ce job dating organisé dans
les locaux de l'entreprise
assystem technologie à montigny le
bretonneux inspiré du concept des speed
dating l'événement se voulait conviviale
enfin nous ferons également un tour
d'horizon de l'actualité économique dans
les yvelines avec un événement emploi
d'envergure qui approche la présentation
d'un nouvel espace de coworking à
montigny le bretonneux et la deuxième
job academy avec l'entreprise sodexo
mais avant de développer tous et y
trouveront ce magazine avec un chiffre
500 21500 euros
cela correspond au montant des prêts
initiative saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accordé en 2010 cette honte ou trente et
une entreprise située sur notre
territoire ont pu bénéficier de ces
prêts d'honneur sans garantie et à taux
zéro et des prêts donc de 5000 à 75000
euros remboursable en trois ou cinq ans
dans quelques minutes nous reviendrons
en détails sur ce dispositif de
financement
mais avant revenons sur ce job dating
organisé dans les locaux de la société
d'ingénierie assystem technologie à
montigny le bretonneux
le principe est simple les candidats
avec 15 minutes pour convaincre et
obtenir un deuxième rendez vous un
événement qui se voulait conviviale
reportage
c'est parti pour 15 minutes d'entretien
en tout quarante candidats vont tenter
de mettre en avant leurs atouts pour
rejoindre
assystem technologies la société
d'ingénierie basé notamment à montigny
le bretonneux et spécialisée dans le
placement de consultants chez des
clients industriels 600 postes sont à
pourvoir en ile de france
tous les profils sont les bienvenus moi
je suis très friande des parcours
atypique
donc je dirais que c'est très ouvert là
dessus la seule la seule chose c'est
d'être d'avoir envie de travailler dans
l'ingénierie d'avoir envie de travailler
dur sur des portes des projets porteurs
d'innovation est effectivement de avoir
travaillé dans le milieu effectivement
technique puisque c'est essentiellement
des projets techniques
la société est présente dans 25 pays et
recherche notamment des candidats dans
l'ingénierie systèmes l'électronique ou
encore le software
quinze minutes plus tard achraf sort de
son entretien
il est 7h à l'aise c'était plus un
entretien pour pour ce faire pour se
présenter de présentation beaucoup plus
que qu'un entretien technique qui
demande plus de réflexion si leur profil
correspond les candidats seront
recontactés dans quelques jours ce n'est
pas la première fois que la société
organise un job dating hamza a été
recruté dans ce cadre en octobre dernier
ça permet de créer une certaine
convivialité initial entre le candidat
et les effectifs de l'entreprise et donc
ça met plus le candidat enfin en tout
cas moi je les ai vécus comme ça ça
n'est plus candidat en confiance
objectif de la société assystem
technologie d'ici le mois de juin
recruter 2000 ingénieurs et techniciens
sur toute la france au moins à présent
notre dossier consacré aux prêts
initiative saint quentin en yvelines ce
dispositif de financement existe depuis
dix ans nous sommes allés à la rencontre
de deux entreprises bénéficiaires
installé sur notre territoire
reportage
une start up qui propose des produits et
services dans le secteur de la réalité
virtuelle ou encore un parka trampoline
située à elancourt a priori ces
entreprises n'ont pas grand chose en
commun et pourtant elles ont toutes et
de bénéficier d'un prêt initiative
saint-quentin-en-yvelines initiative
saint quentin est une association
largement supportée par l'agglomération
dont l'objet est d'accorder des prêts
d'honneur des créateurs développeurs
acquéreurs d'entreprises sont des prêts
d'honneur à taux zéro avec effectivement
une contribution la garantie pendant la
durée du remboursement
mais si le créateur développeur va au
bout de son remboursement ce qui est le
cas dans 98% des des situations alors 50
à l'initiative du rembourse le goût de
sa garantie
donc c'est vraiment à taux zéro depuis
la création de l'association en 2008 254
entreprises situées sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines ont été
financés de qui a permis la création de
8 141 emplois exemple avec la société
jpm pliage située à elancourt en 2014
pour lancer son activité de pliage sur
mesure de l'aluminium
elle a obtenu un prêt d'honneur de 25000
euros ça a été une aide précieuse que
nous avons eues
parce que ils nous ont évité beaucoup
d'écueils
ils nous ont ils nous ont éclairés ils
nous ont je veux dire ils ont balayé le
chemin devant nous ils ont cru au projet
on leur a montré ils ont je pense qu'ils
ont cru aussi en nous la preuve c'est
que bon
on a réussi à faire quelque chose mais
ils nous ont vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
aidé au début de leur aventure ils
étaient trois salariés quatre ans plus
tard ils sont dix une réussite visible
avec leurs effectifs mais aussi avec
leur chiffre d'affaires nous avons fini
notre exercice 2010 est à un million
deux cent soixante dix sept mille euros
pour être précis et nous envisageons de
dépasser les 1 million sainghin milan
cède pour l'un et 2018 à venir
à plaisir l'entreprise ac sol importer
distribuer sur le marché national et en
europe du matériel d'accessibilité pour
les personnes âgées les personnes
handicapées
créé en décembre 2010 la société a
affiché en 2010 est un chiffre
d'affaires de plus de 2 millions d'euros
nous allons traiter les problèmes de
franchissement de franchissant ou de
marche avec des diables électriquement
d'escalier on va traiter des problèmes
d'accessibilité piscine également et
puis certaines certains certaines niches
de marché avec des produits très qui
peuvent être extrêmement innovant une
activité et une croissance qui se porte
bien
l'entreprise ac seul et même récemment
apparue dans le classement des 500
entreprises championnes de la croissance
publiée par les échos
un développement rendu notamment
possible il y a deux ans avec un prêt
initiative saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
50000 euros
j'en étais à mon troisième local qui
était un petit local j'ai besoin de
bouger de et de venir dans les locaux
dans lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui avec
un entrepôt de près de près de 1000 m²
150 m² de bureaux
mais tout ça c'est évident et j'avais
besoin d'un véhicule supplémentaire
j'avais besoin de mattel de manutention
de vrac de stockage et c est donc ce
prêt initiative ce cas il m'a permis
effectivement de nous donner un coup de
main pour la trésorerie de l'entreprise
pour passer ce cap et mais également
nous permettre d'avoir également des
compléments de financement par l'état
par les banques
depuis sa création le prix initiative
saint quentin en yvelines a permis de
mobiliser plus de 19 millions d'euros de
prêts bancaires et pour en parler en
détail jean-luc mais roma rejoint sur ce
plateau bonsoir monsieur vous êtes
directeur entreprises animation
économique et emploi à saint quentin en
yvelines
alors il existe en plusieurs types de
prêts initiative saint quentin en
yvelines selon le projet de l'entreprise
selon la taille de l'entreprise
est ce qu'il ya des conditions pour pour
obtenir ces prêts oui bien sûr d'abord
il faut que l'entreprise soit créé c'est
à dire comme porteurs de projets qui ne
va pas immatriculé son entreprise ne
peut pas bénéficier d'un prêt de notre
part
ensuite il faut surtout que l'entreprise
soit viable avec un projet de
développement ce qui fait l'objet d'un
examen lors d'un comité composé
d'experts qu'on appelle un comité
d'agrément
est-ce qu'il faut un apport personnel
par exemple pour d'autres c'est prêt
vous savez quel que soit le prêt proposé
une création d'entreprise sans apport
personnel est toujours délicat donc nous
sommes nous vigilant de ce point de vue
là et veillons à ne pas mettre dans
l'embarras le porteur de projet ou le
dirigeant d'entreprise qui pourrait
avoir des envies de création de
développement sans apporter d'apport
personnel
c'est un élément un point de vigilance
en tout cas pour nous est ce qu'il ya
des secteurs qui sont exclus tout le
monde est le bienvenu au nom des lions
vous l'avez vu au travers du reportage
qui illustre très bien le
des modalités de fonctionnement de notre
structure de financement tout type
d'activité aujourd'hui peut bénéficier
c'est la pertinence de cet outil au
travers de cette diversité contient des
preuves
donc ça peut être d entreprise
industrielle commerciale artisanale
prestataires de services dont toute
entreprise évidemment de 50 andy bean
peut en bénéficier
alors il ya plusieurs avantages
justement pour ces chefs d'entreprise à
obtenir ces prêts est évidemment avoir
de la trésorerie
et puis être accompagnées aussi un plus
que ce n'est pas qu'un simple prêt il ya
également un accompagnement vous avez
raison de le souligner d'abord il ya
l'accompagnement en amont c'est à dire
que nous préparons au mieux notamment
les business plans nous regardons
quelles sont les conditions et la
situation financière de l'entreprise
pour savoir si elle a des chances de
réussir dans son projet de développement
douter tout un travail qui est fait par
les conseillers l'équipe ce qui cube et
de l'agglomération
le financement en tant que tel qui
permet de notamment à l'effet levier
c'est-à-dire que les banques s'engagent
souvent une fois que les entreprises ont
bénéficié du prêt que nous leur
proposons et puis un accompagnement
poste près je dirais c'est à dire qu'une
fois que nous accordons le prêt notre
job aussi c'est de faire en sorte de
récupérer dans les meilleures conditions
l'argent que nous avons prêté et pour ça
nous organisons nous avons tout un suivi
qui est organisé et nous avons des liens
très privilégié étroits avec les
entreprises qui bénéficient de ces prêts
ans est un dispositif existe depuis 10
ans maintenant qui a évolué qui va
évoluer il absolument donc depuis ces
dernières années nous avons souhaité
faire évoluer ce prêt d'abord les
montants ont évolué et puis le
développement économique est en
perpétuel mouvement nous devons nous
être vigilant et faire en sorte que les
outils que nous proposons d'abord soient
complémentaires les uns avec les autres
vous avez parlé d' accompagnement de
financement la formation également le
sujet de l'emploi qui a fait l'objet
d'un reportage de précédents tout toutes
ces données font l'objet pour nous de
réflexion globale cohérente référence
pour faire en sorte que les outils
soient complémentaires
donc ça c'est un point extrêmement
important et puis vous le savez dans
notre bâtiment ce qui cube qui a ouvert
ses portes hier une petite année
maintenant nous hébergent ou et nous
accompagnons des start-up donc
l'innovation est un sujet important pour
nous et nous savons que le financement
de l'innovation est un élément
extrêmement important et parfois
sensible pour les jeunes entrepreneurs
donc actuellement une réflexion est en
cours pour faire éventuellement évoluer
cet outil est le rendre adapté d'adapter
pardon aux start up qui pourraient avoir
besoin de financement avec des montants
parfois supérieures avec ce que nous
appelons des différé de remboursement
peut-être un peu plus importants voilà
donc des réflexions en cours pour faire
évoluer adapter nos outils dans leurs
questions les informations pratiques
justement si des les chefs d'entreprise
ne regarde comment font-ils justement
pour entrer en contact avec vous et
tentez d'obtenir ce prêt il faut monter
un dossier alors l'ensemble des acteurs
les bons petits chefs d'entreprises qui
font partie de ce dispositif sont
souvent prescripteurs donc eux-mêmes
connaissent l'outil et en font entre
guillemets la publicité auprès des
dirigeants d'entreprise mais je dirais
que le réflexe le plus simple c'est de
passer ou de téléphoner à la communauté
d'agglomération salle kléber sa fille
absolument et je me permettrai
simplement si vous permettez de
souligner que cet outil ne peut exister
évidemment que parce qu'il est fortement
porté par la communauté d'agglomération
de saint quentin mais également parce
que d'autres collectivités son financeur
de cet outil je pense évidemment aux ces
régionales d'île de france
grandin de budget dans dans l'ensemble
de ces dispositifs et la caisse des
dépôts et puis un élément important je
terminerai par là si vous le permettez
également des financements privés et les
condamne des entreprises du territoire
qui croient en cet outil et qui abondent
à ce fonds prêt qui est injectée dans
l'économie locale
merci pour toutes ces explications un
nouvel espace de coworking à montigny le
bretonneux face yvelines qui lance sa
deuxième job academy avec sodexo est un
événement économique d'envergure qui
vous attend le 29 mars au vélodrome
nationale s'est tout de suite dans
l'économie en bref 200 entreprises et
2000 offres d'emploi vous attendre le
jeudi 29 mars au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines dans le cadre
de en piste pour l'emploi un événement
d'envergure qui proposera notamment de
rencontrer des employeurs ou encore de
s'informer sur des organismes de
formation
nous attendons 3000 personnes qui
pourront visiter donc via le showroom
sur différents secteurs les
les exposants d des entreprises il y a
également un booster pour voir avec des
ateliers précisément ce qu'ils peuvent
faire par rapport à l'or leurs demandes
d'emploi c'est-à-dire cv en ligne
image de soi valorisation aussi de leur
cv ce genre d'atelier la fondation agir
contre l'exclusion face yvelines vient
de lancer sa deuxième job academy avec
l'entreprise sodexo basé à guyancourt
durant quatre mois 28 salariés vont
coacher 28 demandeurs d'emploi objectifs
grâce à ce parrainage valoriser des
compétences et retrouver un travail
parmi les 18 personnes en recherche
d'emploi parrainer l'année dernière par
un salarié de sodexo
15 d'entre elles ont retrouvé un emploi
il vient tout juste d'ouvrir ses portes
près de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines à montigny le bretonneux stop
and work est un nouvel espace de
coworking 164 postes de travail sont
répartis sur 1000 mètres carrés des
espaces destinés aussi bien aux chefs
d'entreprises cotées les travailleurs à
leur disposition des bureaux des salles
de réunion une ambiance cosy où le thème
du cyclisme a été mis en avant
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve le mardi 3
avril pour un nouveau numéro à très
bientôt
[Musique]